PROFESSOR: So until now, we
based the safety guideline
on the indoor reproductive
number, which is essentially
the effective number
of new infections
from a single infected
person or per infected person
in the room.
And in many cases, that is the
right variable to think about.
In fact, it's essentially the
most conservative definition
that allows us to limit
the spread of the disease
at the level of the population.
If every room were
doing that, we
would control the
spread of the epidemic.
But we also should think about
the role of the prevalence
of infection in a given region.
In particular, as the
number of infected people
in the population
goes up, we should
be increasing restrictions
to a certain point.
And also, as the
pandemic recedes,
we should then be decreasing
those restrictions.
So there has to be
a role also to be
played in using the
guideline for the prevalence
of infection.
So to describe this, let's
think of a random number
of transmissions
that's going to occur.
So this T here is going
to be the random--
it's a random
variable, which will
be the random number
of transmissions
in the room with all the
usual features so in time tau
and all the other assumptions
about this indoor space
that we've been talking about.
But the important thing
is that this is random
because we don't know--
what we're going
to focus on here
is we don't know how many
people are in the room.
So there are I infected people.
And I here is the random
number of infected people.
There are S susceptible people,
which also is a random number.
And then there is a
transmission rate, which
is the expected number of--
which is the number of--
random number of
transmissions per pair.
So if you take an infected
person and a central person
in this time, there's
a certain probability
of transmission,
which is described
by this random variable TMN.
And so what we're going
to assume here is--
I'll just mention some technical
assumptions, first of all,
that this tau or TMN
is a Poisson process
with a certain mean
rate calculated
by the previous
model that we've been
dealing with with a mean
rate beta times tau.
So up to a certain
point in time,
there's an average
transmission rate beta average.
And that's a Poisson process.
So what that actually means
is that the occurrence
of transmission between
a pair of individuals
can happen randomly
in the time sequence.
At any infinitesimal time step,
it has no memory of the past.
And it's an independent
random event
with fairly low probability
in a given small time
interval but which achieves
this certain random rate here.
So in probability
statistics, we refer
to that as a Poisson process.
We also assume that
each TMN is independent
and identically distributed
Poisson processes.
So in other words, if I take two
different pairs of individuals,
and I consider the transmission,
they're not correlated.
That is an assumption.
Because, of course, if the
infected person is sitting
in one place, you might
expect the people nearby even,
say, within six feet might be
more likely to be infected.
We are leaving that out
because we are considering
airborne transmission in
a well-mixed room where
this should not be
any such correlations
as a first approximation.
Furthermore, we assume that
not only each transmission is
independent but also that
the number of infected people
I and all these transmissions
are also independent,
are uncorrelated.
So basically, the arrival
of infected people
is uncorrelated to how
they're transmitting.
So for example, if we have
a pack of infected people
that arrive, we're not somehow
changing the transmission rate
to change that.
And that's partly we can make
the assumption because we
are interested in the limit of
a small number infected people.
In fact, it's
almost always going
to be 0 or 1 because
the prevalence is not
going to be that high in
the population generally.
And so we can make
that assumption.
And so if we do that, then
what we're really interested in
is what is the expected
number of transmissions
so the expected
value of this T here.
So if you have a random
sum of random variables,
then the expectation
is easy to calculate.
If also the random number is
independent from the variables
you're adding up so there's
no correlation between them,
this would just be the expected
number of the total number
of those variables,
which is IS, just
the total number of pairs
infected and susceptible,
times the expected value of this
tau MN, which is beta bar tau.
And just for completeness, let
me also remind you actually
what this beta bar is just so
that when I keep writing it,
we're clear on it.
It's 1 over tau integral
from 0 to tau of beta dt.
So it's the time average beta.
And we have further
approximated this
by writing the beta
inverse average
is approximately the steady
state value inverse times
1 plus lambda C tau inverse.
So that was a convenient
approximation.
So in our subsequent
calculations,
whenever you see this expression
average of beta times tau,
you could imagine substituting
this expression where
beta bar is given by all
the physical parameters
that we've been discussing.
So this is a very simple model
of the random transmission that
can occur when you
take into account
the randomness in the
number of infected people.
So now let's start to write
down a model for the number
of iffected people.
So the simplest
thing there is that--
I'll write here the random
number of infected persons
is that this should be a
binomial random variable.
And that means that
the probability
that the infected number
is equal to some value N
is the number of ways you can
choose little n infected people
out of N total people in the
room times the probability
that any one of them is
infected, which we'll call pI,
and then qI is the probability
that the others are not
infected.
So the important new variable
that we have here is pI
is the probability a
person randomly selected
from the population and placed
in this room is infected.
And this is also
sometimes called
the prevalence of the
infection in the population.
And then this qI, of
course, is just 1 minus pI.
So it's standard notation
for binomial distribution
is to use q is 1 minus p.
And so let's make some
further assumptions
about this random number
of infected people.
So first of all, by assuming
this binomial distribution,
we are assuming that
at any moment in time,
the number of iffected people is
somehow refreshed continuously
to reflect the same
kind of distribution
that you find in the population.
So the variable I is
refreshed continuously in time
to reflect the
population prevalence.
So people are coming
and going from the room.
But there's always a certain
number of inffected people
that reflects the chance of
running into an infected person
in the population.
So that's a
reasonable assumption.
A more sophisticated
model for a given space
might take into account the
actual probability or rate
of arrival and the rate
of removal of people
and, similar to models
from queuing theory,
might derive a distribution
which is more complicated
and depends on those
other parameters
for the fluctuations
in the number
of infected people in a room.
But this is the
simplest way to start
is that the room essentially
reflects the population
statistically.
Another assumption, though,
which we're going to make,
which gives us some
more simplicity
and also allows us to
be more conservative,
is that we neglect
exposure and essentially
allow infection to happen at
the same rate more than once
even and allow transmission
to proceed at the same rate
where we essentially are
assuming that S is N minus I.
So in other words,
the susceptibles
never get converted into
an exposed group that can
no longer be infected again.
We'll just say that the
rate is still always going
to be I times S where
S is just N minus I.
So we're letting the number
of infected people fluctuate.
But everyone else in the room
is considered susceptible.
That's a conservative
approximation.
Because in reality, the
number of susceptible people
would go down as they
converted to the exposed Group.
Over very long times,
eventually there
be new infected
people generated.
But that's really relevant for
situations like the Diamond
Princess quarantine
where same people
are confined to the same space
for a period, a longer period.
Here, we're really thinking
of just this indoor space that
is reflecting the statistics of
prevalence in the population.
Let me now do a couple
quick calculations based
on this model of some quantities
that we're going to need.
So the first is that given
a binomial distribution,
the expected value of
this random variable
I is just the number in the
room times pI the prevalence.
And furthermore,
the variance of I,
which is the expected
value of I squared
minus the expected value of I
quantity squared, is NpIqI--
basic result for a
binomial random variable.
From there, if you then take
these two relationships,
you can solve for the
expected value of I squared
and find that that is equal
to this Npq plus the Np
quantity squared--
I'll just write that--
Npq plus Np quantity squared.
That's wrong.
And so that's can be written
as I expected value times--
well, let's see here.
We have a qI plus
expected value of I.
And now using this
relationship, if we
look at the number
of susceptibles,
S, the expected value, is just
N minus the expected value of I,
which is Np.
And finally, to
calculate transmissions,
what we're really interested in,
the expected value of I times
s--
so that would be,
if we substitute,
that would be N times
the expected value of I
minus the expected
value of I squared,
which we have right here.
And if we substitute
this expression here,
you see we have a factor of I--
expected value that
we can factor out,
and then we get N minus the
expected value I minus q, qI.
And then, finally,
substituting the expected value
of Is and pI, and
1 minus pI is qI,
you can find that
this is pIqI N N
minus 1, which can
also be written
sigma I squared N minus 1.
So now we basically
have an expression
for the transmission rate in
terms of the number of people
in the room.
So essentially, it's N minus 1,
which, in fact, you may recall,
was the transmission rate when
there's one infected person
and N minus 1 susceptibles.
But time is factor
sigma I squared,
which is actually
the fluctuation
in the infected number.